it doesn't take long when you start to
develop a practice of mindfulness before
you realize that we are virtually
continually bombarded by thoughts it's
there like weather patterns in the mind
lies and there are sometimes nice clear
sunny days but there are an awful lot of
cloudy days tumultuous days rainy days
turbulent stormy weather and again
challenges how are we to be in
relationship to all of that stuff that's
driving our lives and and our narrative
of who I am and and so when you get in
touch with what awareness really is then
you're the first thing you realize is
that those thoughts are not me and
they're not mine they're just like
weather patterns they are impersonal
weather patterns in the mind so then you
can observe them like a scientist like
what is the nature of this thought where
does it come from I mean then they come
like bullets you know fired out of a
machine gun they're very very fast so to
speak that's a quite a militaristic
image but you know another way is
bubbles coming off the bottom of a pot
of boiling water you know if you've ever
watched a pot of boiling water say a
glass pot the the bubbles tend to
nucleate at the bottom and then they go
through the water and they go poof at
the surface so the thoughts are very
similar and that's when I use and other
people often use this term the thought
self liberate you don't have to get rid
of them people misunderstand meditation
is oh I just sweep all my thoughts away
and then I'm in this like Nirvana what
you'll get by trying to sweep all your
thoughts away is a headache
at the most because there's no way to
sweep your thoughts
way they will get you every time and
then you can have millions of thoughts
about mindfulness and meditation and
those are just thoughts - they're not
meditating but when you see that your
not your thoughts then you can watch
them in this kind of impersonal more
sort of if you will observing way with
kindness with self compassion because a
lot of them are heavily loaded with
negative emotion and you can see that if
you don't touch them if you don't do
anything with them if you don't caught
in the them they self liberate naturally
in awareness the awareness is like
touching a soap bubble you know it's fun
for kids and fun for adults too
soap bubble and you touch it and it just
goes so I love that image so like the
thought is the soap bubble and the
emotion - that's you know balancing the
thought and you don't need to do
anything with it
because your awareness is like if not
even a finger it's not corporeal the
awareness just the embracing of it or
the arising of it like in the sky it
goes poof all by itself and don't take
my word for it this is something that
when you sit down and you begin to watch
you'll see this is not rocket science
you can if you don't have to sit in a
cave for 30 years to have that kind of
experience all you need to do is in some
sense get out of your own way now I'm
not saying that's easy that's really
hard but if you can have moments when
you get out of your own way then you'll
see that a lot of the stuff that we get
so caught up in it's like it's a mirage
and that doesn't mean that the thoughts
aren't valuable I mean I think it was
Einstein who said you know if you have
one or two really good thoughts in a
lifetime you're ahead of the curve
paraphrasing so most of our thoughts are
actually kind of mundane or imprisoning
but thinking is a very very I mean it
drives imagination drives creativity so
maybe we need to just create a bigger
arena for our thoughts and watch how
they not only
self liberate but also inform each other
in some sense and then all of a sudden
you see something that no one in the
history of humanity is seen before and
you apprehend it because you're making
your or your something is being revealed
to you I won't say you're making the
connection but somehow a connection gets
made and that's called an insight you're
going to profound insights I mean
Sciences you know sort of storied you
know wonderful stories of Eureka moments
inside where and it's usually not by
driving thinking and banging your head
against the walls writing you thought as
much as you've gone as far as thought
can take you and then you rest an
awareness maybe sometimes it's in sleep
or you wake up out of a sleep and then